le 26 juin dernier catherine mcgregor
patrick pouyanné jean bernard lévy les
dirigeantes et dirigeants d' angie total
energy edf appelait dans le journal du
dimanche les français à une sobriété
d'urgence face à la flambée des prix de
l'énergie pourquoi un tel appel comment
réinventer cette sobriété énergétique
qu'on avait connue après le premier choc
pétrolier au milieu des années soixante
dix avant d'en débattre les détails de
cet appel et ses conséquences avec
cécile 6 ou pas assez de gaz ou
d'électricité l'hiver prochain c'est le
scénario noir que cherche à tout prix à
éviter le gouvernement il incite
particulier administrations et
entreprises à la sobriété énergétique à
savoir un changement de comportement sur
la consommation d'énergie avec pour
objectif une réduction de 10% d'ici 2024
il faut nous mettre en ordre de bataille
et je préfère le dire pendant les
semaines d'été pour qu'on puisse
anticiper des choses
quels sont les consommations d'énergie
auxquels nous devrons renoncer sur la
préparation des grandes industries parce
qu'il peut y avoir des sites industriels
à qui le demanderont de ralentir leur
consommation d'énergie donc c'est tout
ce travail de planification qui est fait
par agnès pannier-runacher est en charge
de ce sujet mais il faut nous mettre
rapidement en ordre de cet appel aux
français à se serrer la ceinture les
géants de l'énergie n'avait déjà lancée
fin juin dans une tribune du journal du
dimanche une prise de conscience des
industriels et du gouvernement qui
arrive un peu tard pour le sénateur
écologiste
guillaume gontard donc moi je suis
plutôt heureux et satisfait que enfin le
gouvernement s'aperçoivent que à la
sobriété c'est pas un gros mot c'est
quelque chose de positif
je regrette peut-être c'est que on parle
de sobriété avec en lien avec la guerre
en ukraine avec les problématiques on a
de production d'électricité notamment à
l'état de nos centrales en centrales
nucléaires et que cette question de la
sobriété on aurait dû s'imposer depuis
très longtemps en attendant le
gouvernement prépare les esprits
particuliers entreprises vont devoir
consommer moins et autrement avec des
leviers notamment sur la mobilité la
gestion des bâtiments mais surtout le
chauffage et la climatisation
climatisation ca c
dans la dans la réglementation elle ne
doit pas être déclenchée en dessous de
26 degrés c'est simple à appliquer et
c'est des économies d'énergie immédiate
si vous baisser d'un degré le chauffage
dans tous les bâtiments tertiaires
et et dans les logements pour être à 19
degrés c'est une économie immédiate de 7
% de notre énergie à long terme le
gouvernement espère réduire la
consommation énergétique du pays de 40 %
d'ici 2050
on débat autour de cet appel à la
sobriété énergétique avec mes invités la
falco bonsoir bienvenue à cette
invitation membre du collectif pour un
réveil écologique olivier babeau bonsoir
et bienvenue président fondateur de
l'institut e sapiens jacquel également
en duplex avec nous en visioconférence
philippe chalmin bon soit philippe merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes professeur à l'université paris
dauphine et spécialiste de l'économie
des matières premières laetitia cuba est
resté à mes côtés éditorialiste
politique dont il ya le court terme et
le long terme d'un autre débat on va
démarrer par le court terme si vous
voulez bien léa falco avec donc cette
après le saut brille était d'urgence et
le mot urgence est important évidemment
dans dans l'appel lancé par les
dirigeantes et dirigeants d -g edf et
total énergie le signal d'alarmé vous le
comprenez vous le partagez d'une
certaine façon abba totalement après il
faut faire la distinction entre ce
qu'est la sobriété ce qu'est ce qu'on va
subir cet hiver pas seulement en france
mais aussi très probablement dans le
reste de l'union européenne qui va pas
être de la sobriété ça va être du
rationnement savez de la privation la
sobriété il faut bien le comprendre
c'est organisé c'est prévu mais c'est
pas subi là on est face à un éventail de
solutions comme vous l'avez dit
parfaitement à court terme et à long
terme mais il faut que la sobriété en
particulier pour les individus soit
encadrée et organisée par les pouvoirs
publics vincent oui c'est vrai il fait
forcément du long terme abh a absolument
voulu retisser sur du court terme c'est
du rationnement comme on va le voir en
en allemagne il ya eu des annonces très
récemment avec des baisses de luminosité
dans l'espace public ils vont fermer des
piscines donc ça va être un impact
direct sur l'espace public et ça c'est
pas de la sobriété la sobriété c'est
essentiel parce que si vous regardez le
mix global
énergétique l'échelle internationale
vous constatez qu'il ya 20 ans on avait
86 % de notre énergie qui venait de
ressources fossiles est là aujourd'hui
on est à 80 4% donc ça veut dire qu'il
ya pas eu d'évolution on n'a pas eu
d'autre d'évolution sensible la raison
c'est que plutôt que de substituer les
énergies alors parce qu on a eu un
développement des énergies bas carbone
du nucléaire et des renouvelables sur
ses 20 ans au lieu de se substituer les
énergies on les additionne et c'est là
le problème principal ça va être de
pouvoir réussir à faire ce chiffre là on
est en train de le faire progressivement
mais il faut qu'on ait des politiques
internationales et évidemment nationale
en france qui aide à passer ce cap
olivier bas vous quand vous avez lu cet
appel lancé par
voilà les patrons encore une fois de
trois grands énergéticiens qui nous
demande à nous de consommer moins
d'énergie bon évidemment il ya le
paradoxe apparent évident comment vous
comment vous l'avez reçu cet appel comme
un signal d'inquiétude signal
d'inquiétude réel et peut-être avec un
petit peu à caractère non c'est plus un
peu dubitative
parce que les les injonctions
effectivement c'est la première phase
pour théoriquement jt la suite qui
serait un rationnement voire des
interdictions je suis pas sûr que ça
suffise pourtant il ya des gestes assez
simple qui pourrait faire que en
quelques heures en quelques jours si on
change de comportement on baisse
énormément la consommation électrique si
on change les led enfin si on prend des
led au lieu de la connaissance c'est dix
fois moins d'énergie si on gère mieux
par exemple les espaces tertiaires si on
chauffe beaucoup moins si on éteint la
nuit les les les enseignes on peut
calculer que l'on peut faire une
économie très rapide de 6% de l'ensemble
des besoins d'électricité en france il
ya énormément de choses à dire on a
publié aujourd'hui chez sapiens un petit
pense-bête de tous les petits gestes
qu'on peut tous faire évidemment rouler
moins vite on explique tout ce qu'on
peut chauffer au micro ondes et pas au
four il ya plein de choses qui peuvent
faire que vous réduisez votre facture
parce que derrière évidemment c'est des
préoccupations très très concrètes pour
les français j'ai une petite question de
novices est ce que pour l'éclairage
public par exemple ce sont les
municipalités qui décide ou pas
d'éclairer la nuit à ma connaissance oui
alors il ya quelques problèmes de
sécurité évidemment comme ceux liés
vous parliez des led un témoignage que
moi j'ai reçu dans une autre émission
sur la chaîne bismarck émission
économique du patron des crèche baby
loup il expliquait que donc c'est une
1100 crèche je crois en france de
mémoire il a décidé de changer les
ampoules toutes les ampoules par des led
ça a coûté quand même 4 millions d'euros
donc c'est un investissement lourd mais
effectivement l'économie elle est
majeure et ça pose une autre question
qu'on va aborder dans ce débat un peu
plus tard parce que là on est
effectivement les questions de de
sobriété à long terme c'est qui porte
les investissements comment fléché
l'argent public pour activer et accéléré
cette transition philippe chalmin je
reviens sur le court terme pardon de
faire comme ça cette parenthèse mais je
reviens sur le court terme et le risque
de black out de coupures de courant ou
d'électricité cet hiver pour parler en
bon français est il réel aujourd'hui
oui probablement pas en france
maintenant il faut raisonner sur
l'espace européen et sur l'espace
européen il est clair que si le gaz
russe s'arrête là vous savez que north
stream 1 s'arrête demain pour ouvrez les
guillemets maintenance technique et cela
pour une dizaine de jours on ne sait pas
si leur ouvriront s'ils trouveront
quelques autres prétextes mais il ya
quand même de fortes chances que a new
town nous soyons dans une situation
extraordinairement difficile en europe
notamment dans l'est de l'europe et en
particulier chez nos amis allemands nos
amis allemands je vous le rappelle ils
ont ils ont une stratégie
qui était à la fois
idéologique et géopolitique idéologique
il voulait ne voulait pas de nucléaire
il ne voulait pas de gaz de schiste
géopolitique qui se sont dit nous allons
mettre le paquet sur le renouvelable et
puis quand il n'y aura pas suffisamment
puisque les énergies tonelab sont
intermittentes on dépendra du gaz russe
et nos amis russes sont toujours là ça
n'est plus cas maintenant donc on a de
vrais problèmes à l'est de l'europe et
nous avons quand même aussi des
problèmes dans notre rue zoo de gaz à
l'intérieur de l'europe ce qui fait que
certaines régions peuvent
s'approvisionner notamment en achetant
du gnl mais par contre les vielles son
qui pourrait y avoir par exemple de
gazoduc entre une espagne qui pourrait
être un peu excédentaire et une
allemagne qui serait déficitaire mais là
il ya vraiment des goulots
d'étranglement donc nous sommes dans une
situation qui risque d'être quand même
très difficile et n'oubliez pas que le
gaz va il conditionne quand même très
largement l'électricité est pour les
français le canal de la crise il va
passer par le prix or et c'est là où
c'est important nous parlons de sobriété
donc on parle de sobriété des ménages je
pense que chacun d'entre nous
confrontés à la hausse du prix de
l'essence par nous essayons de prendre
moi la voiture de rouler un petit peu
moins vite etc mais avons nous
conscience que ça flambe sur le prix du
gaz que ça flambe sur le prix de
l'électricité
aujourd'hui le prix de l'électricité en
europe se baladent suivant les moments
entre 200 et 400 mégawatts heure mais
regardez votre facture edf vous payer 70
euros et donc quelque part nous sommes
en jeu nous somme plafonnée nous sommes
protégés par l'état mais nous n'avons
pas conscience que nous sommes en train
de nous préparer un automne extrêmement
dure et alors je
donnerais je vous la parole un peu plus
tard merci de tous ces détails je vous
donnera la parole un tout petit peu plus
tard je voudrais jouer qu elle se
partage
un petit peu plus dans ce débat mais je
rebondis sur ce que vous disiez sur la
fermeture provisoire on verra bien de
nord stream un effectivement le il ya
une démo qui commencent à apparaître
dans dans les discours de nos
de nos dirigeants notamment elisabeth
board qui n'écartent pas l'hypothèse
d'un vladimir poutine qui ferment le
tuyau
je pense qu'il faut pas se cacher la
réalité la gravité de la situation dans
lesquels on est l'hypothèse qui est tout
simplement ruptures d'approvisionnement
de ruptures de livraisons de la russie
en europe pour l'europe elle est
crédible et je cite également
l'interview de daniel spagnou nash
ministre de la transition écologique
c'est dans le figaro ce matin qui nous
dit il faut se mettre dans les le
scénario du pire car il existe
j'accueille également dimitri carbonnel
bonsoir dimitri merci bonsoir d'avoir
accepté notre invitation au débotté
voilà il ya un autre invité qui
nous a lâché une demi heure avant le
début du débat c'est pas très
sympathique ça arrive il était en
bouclage il est journaliste je ne vais
pas dire son nom mais vous êtes là et
c'est super vous êtes le fondateur de
l'ibo ce faire il vous accompagner les
entreprises dans l'adaptation au
changement climatique
vous participez aux schistes project et
vous publiez 2050 crash ou renaissance
chez libre innova on était sûr dans
cette première partie de débat donc on
parle de sobriété évidemment sur sur les
mesures d'urgence face à cette sobriété
et là je suis sur la question du pouvoir
de vladimir poutine est ce que
finalement dimitri carbonnel cette
guerre en ukraine qui est un révélateur
de notre dépendance aux hydrocarbures
russes certes philippe chalmin disait la
france est moins dépendante que
l'allemagne on le sait mais est-ce que
c'est pas une opportunité à saisir aussi
je mets plein de guillemets à ça mais
pour une une transition à une mutation
plus profondes effectivement c'est
enfin c'est cette crise en fait nous
révèle nos faiblesses d'hier est un peu
en avance de phase par rapport à ce
qu'on aurait vu même s'il ya d'autres
choses on le voit avec la canicule qui
aussi se révèle à nous et donc
effectivement avec tous les guillemets
qu'il faut laisser peut-être
potentiellement une opportunité encore
une fois avec beaucoup de guillemets
bien sûr ce qui veut dire aussi il ya
une autre opportunité que moi je vois
c'est au tour de la loi notamment une
loi son pouvoir d'achat et si on regarde
dans la loi pouvoir d'achat actuellement
il ya beaucoup de mesures à très court
terme qui ne sont plus pour augmenter
nos capacités notamment de gaz ou de
produire plus de charbon en revanche il
a très peu sur la sobriété énergétique
alors qu en allemagne notamment mais
aussi d'autres choses en italie ils ont
mis en place des mesures avec des
recommandations très fort tant que je
pense que ce serait peut-être judicieux
alors il ya plusieurs choses première
chose c'est de réduire à 17 degrés les
la température alors se rappelle pas
pour aujourd'hui mais ce sera pour plus
tard les comédiens et les bâtiments fait
la grandeur de la température des
bâtiments auparavant c'était 19 ° 1
il ya d'autres mesures dans cet esprit
là mais je pense c'est quelque chose
mais a certainement vivre c'est vrai ça
fait partie de la note que vous avez
publié chez titi s'avère si on passe à
18 de grue en fait on fait déjà une
énorme économie chez nous devant ces
noms ou dans une entreprise la clim ça
consomme énormément et ce alors
je vais
on a préféré faire l'émission rigoler
mais typiquement quelques pourcents ça
ça change regardez sur la vitesse
automobile si vous passer de 130 ha sont
ces 30 % de votre votre plainte vous
économisez c'est quand même pas rien
donc si vous êtes m'étais boutabout
toutes ces petites économies à la fin
pour un ménage ça peut faire une
différence importante mais léa falco je
pense ce serait on est tous d'accord
pour dire ce serait une erreur de faire
porter la responsabilité finalement de
la mutation sur les aider de la sobriété
sur les seuls ménages il faut il faut
que c'est ce que dit tout à l'heure il
faut que ce soit une vision beaucoup
plus global partagé que l'état fasse sa
part que les entreprises fassent leur
part etc
si on est dans une simplement en pointe
du doigt les ménages en étant bien
chauffé vous à 18 et et rouler moins
vite sur l'autoroute ça passera pas à ça
ba s'est déjà vu c'est appeler les gilet
jaune ou quoi et puis ça peut
recommencer je pense qu'on sent aussi
dans le temps les tâtonnements de
l'exécutif sur le sujet de la sobriété
sur le fait qu'il soit pas forcément
clair sur la définition que souvent ils
ne confondent avec l'efficacité
énergétique qui est pas du tout la même
chose
la technologie et le développement
technologique l'amélioration des
capacités énergétiques ça va totalement
de pair avec la sobriété c'est pas du
tout opposable mais ça sent le le
tâtonnement du gouvernement qu'il ya
aussi cette peur d'un nouveau gilet
jaune et le ce que j'aime bien utiliser
comme métaphore pour expliquer la part
du privé en tout cas la part des ménages
et la part de l'état c'est une métaphore
de train c'est à dire que imaginons un
train qui soit la transition écologique
balleux les citoyens sont des passagers
qu'est ce que vous demandez aux
passagers d'un train qu'ils soient là à
l'heure qu'ils soient sur le quai qui
trouvent leur place dans le train et
qu'ils aient leurs billets mais c'est
tout c'est pas eux qui font le gros du
travail dans un train ceux qui font du
travail c'est les gens qui est installé
rails c'est à dire d'une partie des
scientifiques qui font la prospective
qui propose des possibles pour demain
d'une autre partie des politiques aussi
qui font fond l'opposition et font
toutes les possibilités d'action et
surtout qui fait le plus gros du travail
c'est les gens qui conduisent le train
et ça c'est le gouvernement ça c'est les
gens qui prennent les mesures
aujourd'hui qui les votent et qui ont
besoin d'enclencher cette transition le
train c'est un véhicule pour aller
jusqu'à son objectif vous que ce soit un
cadrage pour les citoyens et pas qu'on
les laisse se débrouiller tout seul pour
faire 400 km à pied alors il ya aussi un
rôle je reprend la métaphore on peut
dire que pour conduire le train il ya
aussi des collectivités l'occasion ils
jouent un rôle important et ça m'offre
une transition merci pour accueillir
comme ça calme et sûre sur ce plateau de
nouveau quand un rebond soir et on parle
là effectivement de l'impact de cette
crise énergétique les communes
évidemment sont elles aussi impactés
voilà au sénat la chambre des
territoires on parle même d'un sujet qui
monte en puissance
bien qu'ils sont observés depuis 2000 21
par exemple linselles commune de
normandie ou et bien il a fallu fermer
la piscine durant cinq semaines au
printemps car à la facture énergétique
qui avait quadruplé sur un an passant de
40000 euros à 165 mille euros la mf
l'association des maires de france parle
entre 30 à 300% d'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie pour les communes en ce
moment des hausses qui pèse parfois très
lourd dans les budgets des municipalités
d'où la fermeture comme on vient de le
voir de certains services à la
population mais d'autres communes et
bien elles vont et bien pu ne pas
renouveler certains contractuels écoutez
le témoignage d'un maire c'est le maire
devenait d' une commune de l'huile
habitant à côté d'aix en provence il est
auditionné au sénat la semaine dernière
pour 2022 dont quelques chiffres la
commune devrait connaître une
augmentation malgré le groupement
d'achats de 100 % de ses dépenses
d'électricité et de 30% pour le gaz mais
la commune s'implique fortement pour
optimiser la gestion de son énergie tout
d'abord sur le table de la réduction de
la consommation comme le veut l'adage
l'énergie la plus propre c'est celle que
nous ne consommons pas modèle engagé
depuis une quinzaine d'années la
rénovation énergétique de ses bâtiments
donc on voit un les communes qui vont
être particulièrement frugal on pense à
ces communes en côte d'or où on coupe
l'électricité effectivement l'éclairage
municipal la nuit c'est bien la commune
un qui décide de cela et letizia une
autre commune qui est baisse la
puissance de la climatisation dans un
gymnaste alors sujet particulièrement
d'actualité avec le projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat mais
ya pas vraiment de voler sur ce sujet
non tout à fait les sénateurs l'ont
remarqué un d'ailleurs puisque le texte
a été présenté officiellement conseil
des ministres jeudi dernier donc écoutez
à ce propos à notre micro jeudi la
présidente centriste de la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales du sénat
ces hausses de dépenses liées à
l'énergie vont peser sur les ménages ce
que c'est le prix de la cantine ça va
être le prix de la piscine à un moment
c'est exactement comme en économie la
collectivité va prendre une partie mais
il ya une partie qu'on va devoir faire
porter sur l'usagé sinon c'est une
diminution de nos capacités
d'investissement s'est pas vertueux je
pense avec conviction et s'était mise en
évidence à cette table ronde
passionnante qu'il faut un bouclier
tarifaire territoriales c'est bien pour
protéger les collectivités mais encore
une fois ci pour le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages voilà donc on verra demain au
parlement dans les prochaines semaines
s'il y aura un volet comme cela est
réservé aux collectivités territoriales
merci quentin je reviens vers vous
philippe chalmin avec nous et en duplex
un bouclier tarifaire territoriale après
celui qui qui aide les ménages pendant
combien de temps on va pouvoir vivre
sous bouclier tarifaire voyez ce que je
veux dire
écoutez il ya quand même un moment où il
faudra accepter
que nos avoirs des prix de l'énergie
plus cher et comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs et c'est peut-être une
opportunité pour accélérer la transition
énergétique pour revenir d'ailleurs à
des énergies mais vu la taxe demi
européenne on accepte maintenant le
retour au nucléaire mais tout ceci va
prendre du temps le problème est que je
vous donne juste un chiffre parce que le
le coeur du problème aujourd'hui c'est
le gaz naturel y compris dans sa
participation au prix de l'électricité
dans les années 2010 le mégawattheure de
cubes de gaz naturel
il se baladait sur le marché de gros
entre 5 et 15 euros à l'heure actuelle
il vaut 170 euros en séance ont un
certain moment dépassé les 300 euros ne
nous faisons pas d'illusions ça
reviendra probablement un jour à des
prix qui ne seront pas inférieures à 40
à 50 euros c'est à dire pratiquement
quatre à cinq fois plus cher que seul on
n'a que ce que ce qu'on a connu durant
la décennie précédente
il ya un moment malheureusement il ne
pour l'état ne pourra pas continuer à
garantir des prix elle ce week end un
ministre polonais de l'énergie nous a
dit à aix-en-provence écouter on a le
choix entre des prix exorbitants ou des
dettes colossales
je crois qu'il a bien résumé la
situation
au moins sur le court terme
effectivement olivier va bosser c'est
tout le paradoxe de la période c'est à
dire qu'il ya il ya cette urgence de
pouvoir d'achat que voilà que l'on
comprend et à leur demander des ménages
pour lesquels c'est la situation est
catastrophique c'est à dire que les fins
de mois qu'on n'arrive pas à boucler ses
c'est plus le 20 ou le 21 c'est le 13 ou
le 14 ce que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire donc donc il ya cette urgence la
gouvernement et en même temps il ya des
mutations profondes qu'il faut qu'il
faut engager et qu'il faut engager
maintenant on n'arrête pas de dire c'est
les rapports du giec nous le rappelle
qu' on n'a plus le temps ils nous on a
trois ans grosso modo pour pour le faire
quand je n'aimerais pas être à la place
de la première ministre ou demain non
plus mais parce que l'équation il me
semble impossible on est au coeur avec
la question du prix on est au coeur de
l'injonction paradoxale très compliqué
en face de laquelle on est parce
qu'effectivement d'à côté vous avez la
protection de la capacité d'achat mais
pas de la capacité de vivre de beaucoup
de concitoyens le moment ils seraient
touchés très très fortement et qui
serait face à une impasse budgétaire
avec une augmentation des prix s'il n'y
avait pas la couverture de l'état et
puis de l'autre côté vous avez le fait
que le signal prix en fait on n'a rien
inventé de mieux pour inventer pour
faire bouger les comportements quand
quelque chose augmente vous allez
changer de comportement vous allez moins
chauffer un degré de moins c'est 7% que
vous allez économiser dans votre
appartement par exemple bas jusque là on
peut vous dire allez-y on peut essayer
de vous convaincre le jour où c'est sur
votre facture up en général vous êtes
beaucoup plus actifs le problème c'est
que le signal prix si on le laisse à
100% jouer et bien il est beaucoup trop
dur pour toute une partie de la
population donc le problème pour l'état
aujourd'hui c'est arrivé à aider mais
aidé suffisamment quelque part eux pour
provoquer ces changements de
comportement mais c'est ça et c'est une
alchimie extrêmement subtile à trouver
effectivement qui fait que la première
ministre à un travail compliqué dimitri
carbonnel et s'il faut pas part tout
simplement faire respecter la loi il ya
une loi sur les ans et les enseignes
lumineuses par exemple dans les centres
villes pour les commerces si je me
souviens bien la première fois les
beautés en 2013 et on est censé les
éteindre au coeur de la nuit je ne crois
pas beau cet argentin de keller à quelle
heure une heure et sept heures dans la
halle or sauf pour un commerce qui va
ouvrir beaucoup plus tôt mais bon grosso
modo c'est ça la fourchette je pense pas
l'avoir jamais vu dans une ville
française comment on peut expliquer ça
mais je pense je pense que hills a
rejoint effectivement ce qu'a dit
olivier c'est au tour de nos jour d'hui
on l'a pas on nous impose pas grand
chose on n'a pas
il n'y a pas de répercussion sur nous
soit le fait pétillement qu'on était les
alliances elles limitent donc déjà la
première chose c'est que ce père
incertaine dans la croatie sert à ça a
rien d'annoncé de la facilité qui veut
dire une autre chose ça signifie qu il y
compris dans le domaine de la loi il
faut commencer à créer des frictions
pour que les comportements ou consomment
plus d'énergie que nécessaire eh bien on
les réduisent et qu'inversement on
facilite plus les comportements qui
permet de réduire la consommation
d'énergie donc donc là il ya pas mal
effectivement d'éléments qui peut être
fait et aussi peut-être un point pour
rebondir sur la question de prix 1
évidemment c'est par exemple on bloque
les prix par exemple de l'essence a bien
ceux qui ont des 4 4 vont plus
bénéficier de cet avantage que ceux qui
on consomme beaucoup moins d'énergie
beaucoup moins de carburant donc la
question c'est peut-être aussi de
trouver des mécanismes et sur le plan
législatif c'est pas évident des lits
des systèmes qui permettent en notamment
que jusqu'à un certain niveau
effectivement on paye un prix
raisonnable le carburant et que au delà
effectivement basso fois plus cher après
il ya plein de cas d'exception c'est que
c'est une infirmière c'est quelqu'un
d'autre c'est pas évident oui oui ça
pose la question des mesures ciblées à
propos de ces enseignes lumineuses c'est
ma marotte du jour regardez cette vidéo
que j'ai trouvé sur sur le réseau
twitter puisque les commerçants ou les
municipalités font pas appliquer la loi
bayadh et des collectifs comme ça de
jeune à la fois acrobates à la sonde est
ce un collectif rennais ces images elles
ont été tournées à montpellier ce
collectif qui s'appelle 8,6 gang eh ben
ils voulaient faire des enseignes
lumineuses qui devraient l'être au coeur
de la nuit
il ya un interrupteur sur les murs je
voudrais pas que ça donne des idées à
tous avoir des dizaines de personnes sur
les échelles parce que voilà il faut il
faut quand même être acrobates donc ne
faites pas ça chez vous quand c'est là
c'est la phrase traditionnelle non mais
au delà je vois la ccc à la fois à
marans et en même temps révélateur quand
même la falco de notre incapacité à
faire appliquer une loi qui sont tout à
fait simple à faire appliquer et qui
nous fait faire des économies les
escales d'autres exemples à votre
connaissance comme ça deux virages qu'on
a amorcé qui finalement sous une espèce
de force de l'habitude non non non
jamais été menée jusqu'au jusqu'au bout
ce qui est intéressant déjà aussi à
noter sur sur ses vitrines lumineuse
c'est que c'est assez régulièrement des
grandes chaînes qui en fait pour comme
c'est pas assez souvent franchisés mais
comme ce n'est pas le un poids qui est
porté directement sur un petit commerce
ils ont forcément aussi moins
d'incitations à réduire donc là il ya
des choses aussi sur le volet
technologique à faire en particulier si
vous avez un centre commercial
d'installer des thermostats pour la
température d'installer des règlements
ou des grilles pour fermer
automatiquement les lumières à une
certaine heure tout ça c'est des choses
qu'on sait faire et qu'on pourrait faire
et pour répondre à votre question à un
bon exemple je pense et la publicité
aujourd'hui on voit fleurir un petit peu
partout parce que les modèles
commerciaux des entreprises et des
agences de publicité se modifie on voit
fleurir c'est pas nous ces enseignes
lumineuses qui sont souvent en numérique
donc qui change tout les quinze ou vingt
secondes de publicité et elles vont
elles sont pas interdites donc il ya pas
de problème nous l'hiver elles vont être
avec de la vidéo alors devant tu
redémarrer absolument alors qu'à ce côté
de ça vous avez des gens qui n'arrivent
plus à se chauffer il ya des questions
aussi de priorisation de ce qu'on fait
de l'énergie d'où on accepte de la
laisser temporairement ou sur le long
terme ou pas et ça c'est des questions
qui sont pas seulement qu'ils doivent
pas seulement je pense être laissée aux
entreprises qui sont aussi du ressort
des pouvoirs publics
regardez cette liste de mesures qui
avaient été prises juste après la crise
pétrolière de de 1973 c'était l'époque
du fameux on n'a pas de pétrole en
france mais on a des idées voilà ma
génération s'en souvient bien vitesse
limitée sur les autoroutes interdiction
de l'éclairage des vitrines après 22h
monde y était déjà voyez arrêt des
émissions télévisées à 23h bon alors là
je suis pas sûr que ça passerait
aujourd'hui énorme de température dans
l'est dans les bâtiments publics
olivier babeau on est aussi aujourd'hui
une liste assez précise de là où on a
des leviers de sobriété il ya rte qu'est
le réseau de transports à l'énergie en
france qui a sorti sa fameuse étude
futur 2050 et ils ont une catégorie
spéciale dans ce rapport où il montre
secteur par secteur les leviers à
activer pour avoir de la sobriété ils
sont soit individuel soit collectif qui
peuvent être faits par les entreprises
ou impulsée par les pouvoirs publics et
donc en fait on a les ressources il n'y
a pas de ya pas de travail spécial a
commandité c'est le saviez de
contraintes voilà voilà en fait parce
que c'est ce qui manque non mais on a on
a plein de deux curseurs à agiter en
fait mais dès qu'on le voyait dans le
reportage l'ouverture de ce débat où ils
vivent abouya agne espagnol nash et
laminé de la transition écologique qui
évoquait qui mettait une sorte de
pression sur les énergéticiens en disant
il faudrait peut-être récompenser les
consommateurs les plus sobres voyez ce
que je veux dire donc il faut de
l'incitatif aussi faut pas que du
positif et aussi vous voulez éviter la
contrainte il faut de l'incitation à
dire faire que les gens à ternay lille
en quelque sorte d'acte contraire bien
sûr les deux façons d'inciter soit vous
punissez ceux qui font mal que vous
récompenser ceux qui font bien
en face de chez moi il ya un bureau il
est toujours allumée toute la nuit si un
jour vous augmentez vraiment le prix
d'électricité pour ces gens là la nuit
peut-être qu'à un moment donné ce droit
on va faire quelque chose vous allez
créer une bonne incitation moi je pense
pas après peut décider un bonus ou un
malus peut-être que les deux peuvent
être possibles et encore une fois de
façon générale il n'ya que le prix qui
fonctionne alors oui il ya plein de gens
pour qui c'est compliqué et le problème
du ciblage est un problème énorme parce
que ça veut dire qu'il faudrait être
capable quasiment pas de faire varier le
prix comme l'a suggéré bruno le maire
n'est ce pas ce qui est quand même assez
révolutionnaire le prix d'énergie vous
allez payer en fonction de votre métier
les personnes malades il faut aller
assez loin dans les obligations parce
que si on prend les sens bien sûr si
vous êtes une infirmière vous devez
pouvoir l'utiliser etc ça veut dire que
vous devez aller très très loin et ça
aujourd'hui on n'a pas les moyens je
m'aime pas sûr que la cnil d'ailleurs
permettent de faire ce genre de choses
là on a un pro m une impossibilité
bureaucratico technique si vous voulez
intervenir oui il ya eu aussi une
manière un choix d'ailleurs travail
écologique le fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle le name and shame où c'est
grosso modo c'est de dire les
entreprises qui typiquement noms sont
pas sobre donc on pourrait très bien et
d'ailleurs sur twitter ou d'autres il ya
des publicités qui sont dénoncés pour
green washing en faire la même manière
pour les vitrines en dix ans va coûter
telle enseigne ne comment dire laisse
sans cesse à lui met ses lancers et puis
sur d'autres sujets aussi à des
comportements qui correspond pas ils les
salariés aussi pourrait alors sans
rentrer dans la dénonciation mais ce que
je veux dire c'est pourrait aussi
remonter les bonnes pratiques ça c'est
une bonne chose et puis les mauvaises
pratiques et potentiellement pourraient
même obligé certains un game dans
certains cas le mettre sur internet
aussi quelles sont les bonnes et
potentiellement aussi certaines
mauvaises pratiques en même y compris de
manière chiffrée 1 alors il ya la
question de 2
du fléchage des l'argent privé ou public
et lætitia cet après midi c'était le
sommet le cinquième sommet tous france
au château de versailles emmanuel macron
vous savez qu'on vit les pdg de grands
groupes étrangers des homologues
français évidemment pour promouvoir les
investissements internationaux dans
notre pays montant total
d'investissement finalement c'était
combi 6 2 7 milliards d'euros pour 14
milliards du rejet et donc la question
qui devient central c'est la question de
des investissements et des engagements
écologiques de ces enfants est la vraie
question c'est quand même le montant des
investissements et puis les emplois et à
4000 emplois qui en tout cas promis à la
clé et puis aussi un coup de projecteur
sur un énorme projet de méga usine dans
les semi conducteurs porté par deux
entreprises une américaine une franco
italienne qui va s'implanter en isère où
emmanuel mâcon se rendra demain histoire
de bien boucler la boucle et de passer
le message de l'attractivité française
l'elysée ne cesse de rappeler que la
france est le pays le plus attractif
d'europe mais c'est vrai que outre ce
volume se cet aspect volume
d'investissement il y a bien sûr la
sobriété énergétique
tous les progrès faits pour la
transition écologique et puis on
récompense les entreprises qui font des
efforts cet après midi d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron a accueilli les 180 p dg
bien sûr avec moins d'eau le maire bien
sûr avec roland lescure le ministre de
l'industrie mais aussi avec agnès
pannier a menacé ministre la transition
énergétique est d'ailleurs en janvier il
ya eu un mini choose fred est là avait
été annoncée un peu les projets phares
et l'accent avait été mis sur une
entreprise thomas la grande vigne de
recyclage chimiques de plastique de la
société américaine x-man à port jérôme
en ce moment à versailles sont organisés
des tables rondes sur trois tables
rondes 2 sont consacrées aux enjeux de
la transition énergétique donc le
message écologiste avait été privilégié
en janvier cette fois-ci vous dites quoi
calcul politique ou pas je ne pense pas
que ce soit aussi grossier que cela met
quand même il y a bien sûr la volonté d'
emmanuel macron de montrer que son
second quinquennat est placée sous le
signe de l'écologie chaque année par
exemple il ya des prix qui touche france
qui récompense les entreprises l'année
dernière il y a deux entreprises qui ont
été récompensés pour leur action
exemplaire en faveur du climat il ya une
catégorie transition écologique mais
c'est vrai que là cette année
particulièrement oui le message des
manuels macron est très clair et je
rappelle aussi que les projets étrangers
sont quand même aussi aider il ya
l'argent public la part des publics
s'élève entre 5 et 10% et dans sa prise
de parole attendu là en fin de journée
mais le mac on devrait d'ailleurs évoqué
cette question du mix énergétique
français oui c'est une partie de son
discours il veut promouvoir le modèle
français son modèle finalement puisque
c'est celui qui l'avait défendu pendant
l'élection présidentielle
et cette priorité mise sur le nucléaire
vous le disiez tout à l'heure et le
renouvelable avec l'objectif que la
france y fixer un d'attendre la
neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 enfin le lien entre tous french
sommet à versailles et la transition
énergétique et fait constamment puisque
l'exécutif insiste sur l'importance des
investissements étrangers tout
simplement thomas pour réussir la
transition écologique français merci
laetitia léa falcou ce cette question
s'était déjà posée au moment de la londe
du plan de relance france 2030 que
quelques elle part pour
les la transition écologique et
énergétique et puis surtout est ce que
l'on continue de subventionner et
d'aider l'industrie fossile la villa jeu
mais la vieille industrie ça c'est un
vrai choix politique c'est totalement un
choix politique mais elle a ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que c'est plus
seulement on le voit particulièrement
avec les entreprises c'est plus
seulement une question écologique c'est
une question de géopolitique c'est une
question économique ça touche beaucoup
de feux se faire et c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce que les financements
il n'entre pas forcément par la case
écologie ils peuvent entrer par la case
économies peuvent entrer par la case il
ya plein de choses à faire et c'est là
que c'est intéressant sur le sur la
question du choix du financement ou pas
des énergies fossiles les scénarios rte
que je mentionnais tout à l'heure tu
sens vous en avez besoin d'un v6 qui va
d'un pour le coup qui est très très
sobre et qui implique beaucoup de enfin
une sobriété relative jusqu'au scénario
qui demande 50% de nucléaire avec un
échelonnement peu à peu et emmanuel
macron a visiblement choisi ce dernier
scénario donc avec du nouveau nucléaire
ce qui est très bien moi ça me va très
bien il faut aussi qu'on ait des
solutions bas carbone de court terme et
de moyen terme parce qu'on sait bien que
le nucléaire en france pour un tas de
raisons mais du temps à être construits
et donc il nous faut la france est en
retard sur ses objectifs là bas carbone
il nous faut des éoliennes là où c'est
accepter il faut qu'ils aient des
concertations avec les territoires pour
que les habitants est un mot à dire il
faut du photovoltaïque il faut en tout
cas des choses qui fonctionnent et il
faut il faut pas que ce soit au doigt
mouillé et la question de la
planification qui maintenant est un
petit peu partout dans la communication
gouvernementale
c'est une très très bonne chose il faut
le dire parce que ce sont des questions
complexes et qu'il faut pouvoir
planifier et là sur la question de la
sobriété en particulier le secrétariat
général à la planification économique
qui a été créé avec l'accession de
madame bornes au poste de premier
ministre son décret est paru la semaine
dernière son décret d'application est
dedans il ya comme une mission
spécifique la sobriété ce qui n'était
pas à part en avant dans un quelconque
organe gouvernemental
donc ça c'est important et c'est des
questions générales dans lesquels on est
en train de s'engouffrer et dans lequel
l'état français comment ça m'aide et me
ce qui est très bien et maintenant il va
falloir voir évidemment les détails mais
c'est très intéressant ce qu'on dit
parce qu'on vous parle est effectivement
vous reprenez les termes de
planification écologique sauf que et on
revient sur ce cette urgence qui
s'entrechoquent avec les objectifs de
long terme philippe chalmin on avait
fermé il ya trois mois la centrale à
charbon de saint-avold et là on annonce
sa réouverture parce qu'on n'a pas trop
le choix est ce que d'ailleurs on a le
choix ou pas d'après vous
ouvrir sata volts objectivement je pense
qu'on aurait pu c'est plus une mesure de
sécurité qu'autre chose
le vrai symbole c'est d'avoir fermé fait
c'est de fermer fessenheim et de rouvrir
saint-avold à force de vouloir toujours
plus verts ont fini dans noir c'est bien
connu au delà de cela je dirais que la
part du charbon dans le bouquet
énergétique français elle restera
marginale là où elle ne l'est pas je
vous le rappelle 'cependant il est en
allemagne il a largement ouvert les
centrales rouvert les centrales non
seulement au charbon mais aussi à la
limite donc malheureusement sur le très
court terme
excusez moi j'ai une sonnerie est ce que
ce n'est pas le cas je ne sais pas si je
vous l'aï dit répondre au téléphone ou
c'est me réussissait à guantanamo
mais d'honneur ce qui est clair c'est
que
sur le court terme on n'a pas
malheureusement in or mais man de
solutions pour des raisons de sécurité
gardez-les éventuellement la possibilité
de tirer sur les centrales à charbon si
l'hiver est particulièrement rude si
nous n'arrivons pas parce que nous avons
des semaines à venir qu'ils sont pleines
de 6 à l'heure actuelle on est un taux
de remplissage de nos réserves de gaz de
l'eure de 60% vous savez que l'objectif
est de 80% pour septembre on l'a même
parler de 100% pourra-t-on y arriver que
va-t-il se passer du côté russe il n'est
pas du tout sûr d'ailleurs que la russie
arrête totalement de livrer car pour
l'instant gazprom n'a jamais revenu en
arrière sur les contrats pour l'instant
gasprom utilisent des raisons techniques
des pièces qui lui ait manqué la
dernière fois aujourd'hui une
maintenance pour fermer nord stream
mais non ils n'ont pas pour l'instant
remise en cause le principe des contrats
et donc il n'est pas impossible que
continuons être un peu approvisionnés
par les russes et que à ce moment là
nous atteignons le town dans une
position un petit peu meilleure ensuite
voyagé j'ai deux questions climatiques
l'année dernière on l'a oublié c'était
bien avant l'ukraine très vite c'est la
conclusion gaz naturel a flambé parce
qu'il n'y avait pas eu de vent dans le
nord de l'allemagne les deux questions
est-ce qu'il va y avoir du vent en
europe cette année et est ce que l'hiver
sera froid n'ont effectivement pas les
économistes comme les métérologues nous
réclamons le droit à l'erreur
on va terminer là dessus merci philippe
chalmin vous allez pouvoir répondre au
téléphone je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur à l'université paris-dauphine
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat et dimitri carbonnel partie
particulièrement voilà ça s'appelle a
invité réactif et donc je rappelle le
tilt est sympa accessoirement mais ça je
le savais déjà
2050 crash ou renaissance c'est titre de
votre livre qui est publié chez libre
innova et qui a c'est un pavé avec
énormément de bonnes idées de solutions
et c'est quoi votre concept en deux mots
c'est la société boule de gui en fait
grosso modo c'est vraiment de mettre
beaucoup plus ce soit de ressources ou
de pouvoir de décision dans les
territoires pour xaxier un minimum de
résilience il ya une sorte de filet de
sécurité au niveau du territoire parce
que l'état pourra pas tout faire en loi
avec la canicule et comment lire les
incendies c'est un parfum la résilience
grâce aux territoires la société bull de
gillies et la soliste de dimitri
carbonnel merci encore à tous d'avoir
participé